a woman is recovering after a Jaguar
attacked her at an Arizona zoo zoo
visitor recorded the aftermath on his
cell phone officials say the woman tried
to get close to the animal to take a
selfie it happened at the wildlife world
zoo aquarium and safari park near
Phoenix Saturday Anna Werner is here
with how another quick-thinking zoo
visitor came to the rescue
Anna good morning good morning well the
woman in this incident says no I wasn't
attacked she instead told CBS News she
calls it a crazy accident the Jaguar has
been taken out of the exhibit while the
zoo investigates but officials say the
animal will not be put down because it
was not at fault cell phone video
captured the unidentified woman crying
out in pain after her encounter with a
Jaguar at the Wildlife World zoo for
ities say the woman crossed this
concrete barrier to take a selfie when
the animal reached out and clawed her
arm
Adam Wilkerson took this video the claws
that were retracted were definitely
outside of the cage and grasped around
her hand and she was holding it or her
other hand arm with her hand attached to
the pod screaming screaming screaming to
get out his mother used a water bottle
to get the Jaguar to let go of the woman
I grabbed it and started to push it into
you know the cage and so that's when she
took one paw off and grabbed the bottle
with the mouse the woman tells CBS News
she's grateful to her rescuers but
unhappy their video was made public in a
conversation with CBS News she did not
admit to entering the enclosure
surrounded by that concrete barrier
which does meet federal guidelines when
people do not respect the barriers
there's always a chance that there might
be a problem just last year another zoo
visitor said the same Jaguar scratched
him as he was taking a video just one
swipe with a paw can do a lot of damage
it's also really hard on the animal it's
really stressful animal rights activists
say invading the animals space causes
anxiety but the draw of posting a great
picture on social media has prompted a
growing number of people to do just that
putting their safety at risk
we're in a part of
our culture where we want that great
picture but that's a to get great accost
it could have been so much worse for the
animal and the person who tried to
intercede and help her well the woman
received stitches she was released
yesterday from an area hospital the zoo
says she met with the zoo owner on
Sunday and apologized for her actions
the zoo says she admitted she was wrong
at least she knows it was a bonehead
move and she's lucky that she was not
really hurt but I love what the guy in
the in the piece said the the barriers
are there for a reason no to self
yeah yeah stay away from the attention
people